[Music]
go out to amy in
palm springs california amy how are we
doing
hi dr d hi anthony thank you so much for
taking my call
you bet how can we help uh i have a
relationship
question um my fiance who i've dated for
10 years is a huge procrastinator
and his response to things that i tell
him to do is that i'll do it later or
i'll do it after work or i'll do it
tomorrow but he never does anything
until the very last minute and it
stresses me out
so i nag him and i end up being the
annoying person
um how do i deal with someone who is a
procrastinator
i wonder if i'm approaching it the wrong
way since it doesn't seem to be
effective
and i'm a bit frustrated i wanted to
hear your
your and anthony's thoughts anthony what
do you think
no you're the expert in this field doc i
know but i want to hear from you how do
you help somebody stop procrastinating
you can't help someone stop
procrastinating say what
what do you mean what do you mean i mean
i don't control another person's
uh way they think stop it anthony you're
being revolutionary here
hey amy he's exactly right at the end of
the day there's nothing you can do
what i can tell you is you can
absolutely make sure that your
relationship ends up in a dumpster fire
and that's by
nagging by trying to control him by
trying to
beat him up with a stick that is a
surefire way
of getting off the off the tracks now
he's got responsibility for getting this
thing off the tracks
but that is not a way to get it back on
right
have you sat down with him outside of a
hard conversation right so let's say you
said hey i need you to pick these towels
up please pick these up
and he's like all right as soon as this
commercial is over i'll get them and
then you go to
read a book you go to re-roof the house
whatever awesome thing you're doing you
come back and the towels are still
sitting there and he's asleep
and then you you lose it you take this
towels you think about smothering him
with them and then you just throw them
at him instead and then you'll have a
big dust up
have you ever outside of that situation
have you ever
been out on a date with him have you
ever had dinner with him and said hey
tonight i just want to talk to you just
you and me
go to a restaurant or sit down at your
house wherever you need to do it
and say i don't feel like you're taking
me seriously i don't think you're a
contributing partner to this
relationship i ask for i ask you to be a
part of things and part of it is
we agreed on cleaning up we agreed on
doing these things together and you're
not helping in fact you're not being
honest with me when you say you're going
to do it
and talking about it in an off off scene
situation
have you ever tried that no i haven't
okay i've actually i've actually you
know um
when he doesn't do things like i tell
him to clean his room i'll remind him
daily to do it
and then when he finally does do
something that i that i wanted him to do
after weeks later i i said oh good job
or i praise him and it doesn't seem like
it
amy amy amy this is your fiance or your
or your pet yeah wha wha what i'm
confused my fiance is your fiance or
your son
amy you're telling it how old are you
i'm 32. how old is your fiancee
he's 34. and
you're telling him to clean his room
i can't be quiet here uh and i want to
respectfully say this
i i don't think the problem is on him
solely i think it's on you
uh part of it too because here's why
you've been with this guy for 10 years
this hasn't just started and if my
daughter came home and said
dad i have to tell my grown man
who's 34 years old to clean his bedroom
and the only way he'll do it is if i
give him praise
no disrespect that's what i do
i'm not going to say that but i'm just
going i'm gonna say that's what you do
with a young child
or a pet right so you're dating a grown
man but it sounds like he's a little boy
in a grown man's body
and then it makes me question you
because it's like
what are you attracted to so i
think the communication problem is on
both sides not just his
but you as well because how can you go
10 years and you just told us
that you've never even said something to
him
so i think i agree with you y'all both
need to go out there and just sit down
and have a clear communication and you
need to voice everything that you're
concerned about
he needs to voice everything he's
concerned about and at that table
you all need to identify all right do we
want to move forward because 10 years
dating someone
man i wish i could boy
so amy imagine that for us how's that
conversation going to go
10 years um
honestly i don't know how to start it
okay
are you more and i'm not being ugly here
are you more his mom
or are you more his fiancee are you more
his
maternal figure who takes care of him
and cleans up after him and makes sure
the bills are paid
or are you preparing to marry somebody
that y'all are going to be co-partners
co-create a future together
that's the second option so that's where
you feel like you are or that's what you
want to do
i i want it to be that way there you go
so i know where you want it to be where
is it now
uh it's right now where i'm doing
everything as being more of a maternal
person okay so what i need you to do is
this
um after a long time together couples
get in ruts they get in
routines and all of a sudden you look up
and you have a conversation with two
guys you've never met and say hey is
this
how does this sound and we both lose our
minds but i don't want to miss
the pain here i don't want to miss the
the you're stuck on those same railroad
tracks you are in a rut
and you have your foot on that gas and
that car is just spinning a hole deeper
and deeper and deeper
you have to have to have to
create a future together with a shared
vision you've got to stop telling a girl
man to go clean his room
you've got to stop saying i want to
build a future with a guy that i've got
to remind with
praise to do basic hygienic things
you're going to have to have a voice in
your relationship where you say hey
here's what i need
to be whole in this relationship here's
what i need from you as a partner
what can i do to support and love you
that's what relationships are
they are not tell somebody telling other
grown people to clean up after
themselves
and then pat them on the head and saying
good boy and getting them a whopper with
cheese and going on about your day
amy i'ma say something and this is my
opinion this is not dave ramsey's
opinion this is not john's opinion this
is my opinion so i
i will take all the heat from youtube
when i say this
but i want you to ask yourself do you
having any insecurities
with inside of yourself because i think
that maybe you should step back
and ask god should you be dating because
any woman
that will allow a man to do that i
question does she know her own value
and i hear a woman who is valuable i
hear a woman that is sweet i hear a
woman that is
caring but i wonder do you know that's
your value
um and and and if you don't i would
definitely say
step back and even before you meet
really talk to yourself
and really get to know yourself so this
way when you go to him
he's going to see a different woman when
he looks into your eyes
and says okay that's the woman that i
want i'm going to change
and if he doesn't want that woman he's
going to walk away or
you have to walk away because the only
way this change
is by you you can't depend on him
because he's not changing
you have to make a change in yourself to
force him to change or you have to be
willing to exit
especially after 10 years i i think
this is a great example of so often
anthony women are conditioned to make
sure
everyone else is okay yeah everyone
else's needs are taken care of yeah
i will pat you on the head i'll clean up
after you i'll do all this other stuff
you're wearing a woman well but it's
also a a
it's a frustrating social conditioning
and on the other side
guys live in this world where i'm just
going to sit here
right what guys not me you're the
exception of the reptile
yeah you're one of my peers you don't be
just sitting there
that's right if you've got a perfect
show she had to tell you to clean up her
room
i'm telling her to leave you today
trust me she won't be telling you that
real talk